in a year where everything changed when
we were forced to question all we
thought we knew when nearly all hope was
growing dim mana but here comes 2017
Donald Trump wins the presidency from
the country that brought you 2016 and
November 8 comes a whole new kind of
comedy yeah this country man one where
anything can happen
Donald J Trump will become the 45th
President of the United States we're the
only thing to expect is the unexpected
you're awake by the way you're not
having a terrible terrible dream also
you're not dead and you haven't gone to
hell this is your life now this is our
election now this is us this is our
country
featuring mass triggering destruction of
safe spaces it's gonna talk
empty threats of suicide I'm literally
about myself and I'm not kidding and
futile protests galore so hold on to
your hats and get ready because it only
gets better this one's here to stay
we're gonna win so much you may even get
tired of winning and you'll say please
please it's too much winning we can't
take it anymore
mr. president it's too much and I'll say
no one is it we have to keep winning we
have to win more we're going to win more